how much longer after karl marx wrote
his book communist manifesto we had a
country
that was a communistic country running
on his philosophies about 50 years right
yep so 50 years 45
okay about 50 years of that so nolan
came out in 71 it is now
2022. so
50 yours
there's not one country for libertarian
time is now and the only ones you can
say maybe new zealand's got an element
of it but not necessarily fully there so
why why hasn't a
if this philosophy is so effective and
so peaceful and so necessary and so free
why hasn't one of these countries chosen
to take it up as their that does their
you know way of running their country
well here's what as milton friedman
right as
someone you're a fan of i mean he would
say it this way right that if you want
to look the united states of america
between the end of let's say take the
end of the civil war to about 1910. so
about 1865 to 1910. in this and i'm not
saying everything was perfect back then
i'm not saying it was a libertarian
society but economically speaking
looking at it there was no central bank
there was no income tax there was
essentially no federal regulation of the
economy the national spending was
something like two percent of the
national income by today's standards
you'd be like this is basically
anarchist there's literally no
government intervention and in this time
period
we had the largest at the time expansion
of wealth the biggest improvement in the
lot in life of the average man in the
history of the world there's the wealth
that had never been thought of before
was created now the problem that i think
freedom has is that
also a milton friedman quote he goes you
know freedom is in the general interest
but it's not in anybody's special
interest here's the issue and so what
happens is as the wealth gets created
more and more the government tends to
siphon off it the parasitical class
tends to siphon more and more and more
and this grows the government and so
this is the issue that we've been
dealing with it's like because we're the
richest country in the world it was
because we were the most free country in
the world we become the richest country
in the world because we're the richest
country in the world we now have the
largest tax base this leads to the
government getting bigger and bigger and
now we have the largest government in
the world the largest most powerful
government in the history of humanities
than the united states federal
government so that is the challenge but
it's not as if no countries maybe no
country has embraced the entire
libertarian program that's also true for
marxism it's not as if any country
really embraced every single word he
ever wrote um but the countries who have
embraced more freedom have been the most
the most successful countries in the
world um so we just i i think my view
for what the solution is to that is to
create as much of a libertarian populist
uprising as we can have yeah i think the
more people that believe in these values
the more libertarians there are the more
likely we are to live in a different
libertarian and independent
uh well i think libertarian is a
philosophical outlook whereas
independent just means you are not part
of one of these two you know what i mean
or any major parties or any of the
parties one's a political affiliation so
you can mutual philosophy i mean you
could be both a libertarian and an
independent or you could be a member of
the libertarian party and an independent
thinker but an independent could just be
something different than what the
establishment is whereas we are
something specific people who believe in
human liberty and the reason that a lot
of independents aren't coming to the
libertarian party and for that matter a
lot of
most self-described libertarians aren't
members of the libertarian party so for
example uh one of the best ways you can
judge if someone's a libertarian or not
is how they register in their voting in
most states the difference between uh
registered libertarians in states that
have party registering or have third
party registering and members of that
state party is 99
yes
it's like one percent of n and i'm not
talking about the population of the
state i'm saying people that have
already identified as libertarians are
not joining the party and the reason is
and i think this is what you're saying
you're you're not asking from a from a
philosophical standpoint you're saying
why are people not becoming libertarians
and i think the answer is because our
focus has been wrong we talk all the
time about what libertarians are going
to do for the wars what we're going to
do for healthcare what we're going to do
in dc and with the federal reserve and
those are good things to talk about but
long before the vast majority of people
who actually decide who is in office
decide to give us a shot they want to
see how we're going to deal with things
in their backyard i'm trying to talk
about it no and i know you are and the
reason that i coming out of the campaign
the reason i that i started you are the
powers because we're doing exactly that
localized grassroots single issue
activism show people what libertarianism
looks like as policy how it actually
looks like in practice instead of these
great theories i can come in here and
sell you the best idea possible but if
it never happens then it makes just as
much sense for me to say you know the
way we're going to deal with china is by
me throwing magic thunderbolts at them
and then that'll fix it with the
likelihood of us winning the presidency
right now i might as well give that
answer it makes more sense for our main
focus to be on where we're actually
already winning sometimes despite
ourselves which is at the local level
which grows us as a party it shows
people that we aren't this you know
utopian pipe dream it's actual common
sense feasible things that can be done
and we can build up from there and we
build the infrastructure because not
only when the rock converts to
libertarianism will he be able to win
because we have the structure in place
but he'll want to in the first place
instead of just joining one of the other
parties and trying to change it from the
inside which never happens that's a
that's a scam there but the the reason
that they would do that is because right
now we don't have much to offer them so
we have to build from the ground up and
if we don't do that then we're going to
be here 50 years later talking about in
theory how ending the federal reserve
would end our 400 inflation rate in 2018
after i won ballot access and party
status for my for my party libertarian
party in new york i crossed the state
again in 2019 after i had lost but i by
the way to your point there were 7 000
registered libertarians in new york
state in 2018 i got a hundred thousand
votes he's a prototype of what i'm
talking about exactly that's exactly
what he said so then after that i
crossed the state again and in 2019 we
had 107 victories at the local level we
went from zero libertarians to 107 in
one year and then the state afterwards
decided oh yeah we're going to change
the rules on how you can get in the
ballot so now we couldn't get the ballot
anymore you might say what does that
mean most people don't realize getting
on the ballot just being on a ballot so
you can have a choice to vote for me
costs hundreds of thousands of dollars
takes massive amount of people are going
to back you came in the ballot when the
people independence came to me with tons
of money and said larry we want to run
as independent in 2022 people ask me
that 2022 2020 i'm sorry 2020 what about
independent i said great you're gonna
have to have 40 million dollars and you
probably won't be able to get in all 50
states you're like what so yeah well we
have that money i know you can raise 50
million dollars but you can't get
through the red tape to be on every
single ballot in 50 states just run
libertarian we've already done that
already they're like well we don't want
to depend it you can't if you could run
independent there'd be a president
bloomberg right now
it's impossible ballot access is one of
our biggest issues which is why i run to
gain ballot access so people can't on
the ballot and we just got hammered
again in new york state now i got to get
45 000 signatures in six weeks and they
just made new laws that destroyed our
our local um congressional districts so
now congress people can't even get on
the ballot independent because there's
no congressional deal let me let me ask
you they hammer us this way tell me who
is a major influencer in america today
that has
libertarian tendencies would you put
musk in that category or no no i put
musk in that category rogan in that
category absolutely i put drew carey who
talks to seniors every day in his tv you
put theo in that category yeah he feels
in like i think he's he kind of like
he's certainly very interested in
libertarian ideas i think he he kind of
is somewhere between a populist yeah and
he's invented a libertarian musk what
would you say musk is musk i think he's
actually a left libertarian i think so
is rogan i think both of them are left
libertarian okay so who has sat down
with these guys to try to get them to
start selling the concept of
libertarians well i'm not rogan i'm
talking mostly yeah i mean rogan's joe's
a good friend of mine um but there's in
terms of i've i'm trying to work on him
to get yes to get peter thiel and those
guys on board but i think that i mean
there's a guy to do that peter thiel i
believe uh donated to ron paul's
campaign um i believe so i think he's
well aware of these ideas also weirdly
enough uh jack dorsey like tweeted out
uh murray rothbard article man economy
and state which to me is like the
greatest libertarian piece of writing
and he's a big crypto bitcoin yeah he's
kind of in that world but then but i
don't i don't doubt something i don't
know what his deal is though like
because he's like now he you know he's
like elon musk is right no one should be
kicked off twitter and you're like can i
ask you you know you were there for a
while man yeah could have heard this
larry brought up andrew yang we had
andrew yang what a month ago yeah he
literally back he's endorsed me i'm
literally back by the forward oh my
question
okay so
he's starting this new uh forward
forward okay
that's uh essentially a competitor
libertarian party no no an ally an ally
it is an ally 100 because they want to
break the duopoly just like we do we are
100 allies okay but aren't you guys
yeah we have heating for votes
but yes we're not competing for votes
but we are allies and crushing duopoly
that's why he realized you can't it's
hard to run within the party right he
realized it amash realized it tells you
gabriel left democratic party i mean
maybe not officially but in reality she
has they're all leaving because they
realize that two participants doesn't
work that's why we're allies we are all
allies it's like when the japanese
invaded uh china right the there were
the maoists and then there were the
chiang kai-shek people they got together
to fight the japanese that's us we're
together to fight the empire oh that
doesn't end very well it doesn't it
doesn't but let's hope we change that
what we we learned from our mission the
enemy of my enemy is my friend
so what about the green party we work
together i know howie hawkins how it was
my friend we're both marines and by the
way howie hawkins is so far is so far
left we get our guns back he's actually
pro 2a he's a real socialist he
literally was he literally was the
socialist party nominee in uh in 2020
and he is my friend and we are absolute
allies is there enough room for all
these parties that are getting one
percent uh if if you add them all up we
get remember new york state is a
plurality state i don't need 51 of new
yorkers i need 35 percent of those who
vote
there are 18 million new yorkers about
12 million eligible to vote 10 million
register vote about 6 million actually
vote so if i get about 2 million to 1
million votes i win so i need about 1 in
8. i don't even i don't need a majority
any one in eight and i'm the guy larry
for the people you were talking
off-camera what how are the conditions
in new york what's happened in new york
the last 10 years oh my god horrible new
york we've lost over 2 million people in
the past 11 years to include this guy
right here which makes me angry but yes
we've lost lots of people from new york
they all take off and they leave and
they leave because we're too oppressive
right our government is so oppressive
that it breaks up families my mother had
to retire and eventually die in south
carolina because she couldn't afford
living in new york state and she left
her grandchildren for that it's terrible
new york state is a basket case where we
now have a budget that went from 170
billion to 220 billion while we're
losing millions of people
that math doesn't work we just keep
raising our budget we just keep making
things harder we keep it making more
rules and regulations we keep crushing
our families and then we wonder why some
realtors are telling me that a thousand
people a day are leaving if you guys
have noticed that you have some much
louder more obnoxious neighbors lately
yeah
i showed you the cover from the wall
street journal about how miami's are
basically up in arms about how much uh
rent has increased florida has read
because of new york florida used to be a
swing state but we have exported all of
our republican our red and conservative
voters to florida we made florida a red
state it was a purple state before new
york jessica is there any state worse
than california i mean what's going on
there oh no i had a question for you
about what you think of the recent
development about in new york not even
needing to be a a citizen to vote yeah
it's to they they can't do it in federal
elections but they can do it in local
elections that's going to be come into
effect in new york it's a terrible idea
for many reasons but one of them is
because it's only 30 days
which it just it makes it extra bad so
maybe maybe i should go visit so i can
come vote for you you can you should
but yes show up for 30 days or exactly
yeah just stay for 31 days and you can
then and you can vote in new york city
that's a city thing not to say thanks to
anything so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]